it changed my life I had someone teach
me a few years ago and all of a sudden
it's like everyone's like oh you make
the best eggs and it's like because the
heat's not well it's I I really do make
like the most disgusting eggs for my
daughters and I just but I don't know if
they would like the soft scramble yeah
it's a little artisanal it's a little
sophisticated for them but all right
here we go
welcome to the Drew's News podcast where
we're giving you all the fun news all
the quirky inspiring in yes informative
stories that exist in the world because
we need them and today we're covering
everything from Dolly Parton's bombshell
announcement to Jason momoa's butt I had
to just say but like that because I got
so excited
um and this week we have a fellow
podcast host and writer who has been in
every cool established publication out
there from GQ to Oprah Magazine to
Rolling Stone it's someone I personally
have followed since I believe you
started on social media it's Evan Ross
cats
thank you so much I am just really
excited that we're going to be
discussing Jason MMOs but I feel like
that's important you know I'm actually
gonna need a reference on that picture
because I haven't seen it yet do we have
a photo of it I have a photo okay good
okay
um and I'm bummed I missed that on
social media Okay evan your podcast uh
shut up Evan focuses on one person
um of note per episode is there someone
who you haven't gotten to work with yet
that is a dream guest for you so the
obvious answer would be Kim Cattrall
because I feel like she doesn't give a
ton of interviews and obviously there's
a lot to discuss uh dying to crack that
one but like I don't think I would get
there with her so the person that I've
been thinking about lately is
Ann-Margret
um just because I just rewatched uh is
it cat on a whip yes wait no cat kitten
with a whip yeah her film kitten with a
whip I just rewatched it and then a
Wikipedia in her and I'm like oh my God
she's still alive and I was like I just
think that to talk to someone who's been
a part of Hollywood for decades and
decades in the studio system like that
she just must have so many incredible
stories but I also want to find out like
what does she make of this 2022
Hollywood
I it's so weird that you would mention
her name because I was just ruminating
about Ann-Margret all day yesterday this
is so freaky I remember her like in Bye
Bye Birdie with the pink halter top or
crop top and I kept thinking about how
Ann Margaret what did people think when
she came out in those black tights and
nothing but a pair of tights with like
basically no bottom and she sort of was
such a rule breaker and you think about
her and Bye Bye Birdie or with Elvis and
you know all of these and she was so
beautiful and talented and interesting
so weird you would say that well it's
interesting too because the role in
kitten with the whip I mean she plays an
assassin and it's just so fun that I
think she was like 23 24 at the time she
had just come off of Viva Las Vegas and
Bye Bye Birdie yeah and it's just like
this is where she chose to go like she
was just someone who took on really
exciting projects from such a young age
and I just think she's got stories and I
want to hear from her shall we hit some
headlines we must all right it is Drew's
news after all which feels weird to say
my name but it's got the word news in it
and that's the point yeah all right
Story number one let's start with some
casting news straight from variety a
very important Hollywood uh you know
what do you call it a industry trade
there you go okay perfect Jeff Goldblum
is in final talks to join the film
adaptation of wicked as the wizard
Ariana Grande is playing Glinda and
Cynthia erivo is playing alphaba
thoughts uh on Jeff as the Great Great
and Powerful I would say Oz but yeah
it's odd yes he's a great empowerment
yeah yeah I mean I'm excited I just need
things to move along so wicked first
opened on Broadway in 2003 uh as people
listening to this podcast know it's
currently 2022. it's been 19 years it
was a hit from the get-go it's an IP
people know the Wizard of Oz so there's
already that you know no barrier to
entry there you don't have to see the
show we have these two superstars cast
in the movie we're in rehearsals right
now in London why are we still in the
casting phase of this movie we need to
move things along it's weird that you
said that because when I heard it I
thought wait isn't the movie done
um but I guess that is the sign of a
real anticipated movie because it's true
it's been being spoken about for so long
that in your mind it's about to come out
right not about to be made
um I love Jeff Goldblum I do think that
he will come to play and that's a juicy
part and I want to see someone like in
the best way go for it ham it up he's
got the body to do it he's got the body
language he's got the sense of humor
he's got the odd delivery everything
about him he's handsome but like and and
debonair and Suave but also leaves a
little bit of like kind of mystery
Intrigue and sense of danger like he's
perfect totally I think that get him to
London on the next flight out right now
get these rehearsals going get this film
made I'm also concerns not the word but
they're dividing the film into two parts
right they're releasing part one and
then they're releasing a year later part
two and I just feel like I'm gonna see
part one it's going to end with Defying
Gravity for those that don't know it's
the big closing number to act one of the
show if if you don't know it you should
know it it's a great song is it where
intermission is yeah it's right before
intermission and then but instead of a
15-minute intermission we're going to
have to wait a year and so I just I say
bring back the film intermission you
know back in the day of course yeah and
it's like hey give us 15 minutes go pee
fill up your popcorn and let's get to
act two I don't need a year in between
these movies interesting marketing plan
though kind of a you know first to bat
with uh something like that I'm trying
to think of other films that have done
that well so Kill Bill was famously
supposed to be one film and then was
divided into two but I feel like I have
to imagine I don't know this for a fact
I have to imagine they went in and
retooled what would have been the back
half of the first film to make it a more
complete film which might happen with
Wicked Stephen Schwartz is very much
alive so hey you know we'll be talking a
few years I'm gonna be like thank God
it's two movies but right now I'm just
like I want this movie so bad I don't
want to have to to keep waiting so Jeff
Goldblum again fly him out get the rest
of this cast and Order cameras up let's
go all right I didn't know that they
were separating it into two movies a la
Kill Bill which how far apart did Kill
Bill one and two come out from each
other I think one year okay well that
worked for me yeah no that totally
worked um I just went to bed to Kill
Bill too the other night
um not a bedtime tale not so much nope
but I loved it okay our next topic
former Child Star Raven Simone is
finally feeling comfortable in her own
skin saying quote I have a lot more
control over how I present myself up
until my late 20s there were people
telling me how I should look and it was
just easier to be told what to do but
now that I'm feeling empowered by the
new generation of just be yourself on
camera and my own self really marinating
in my own juices and understanding who I
am and who I feel comfortable being I'm
able to present how I feel as Raven
Simone the Entertainer
um okay interesting that's uh you know
marinating in her own juices
my own juices yeah we should all
marinate in our own juices a little more
than like speaking before we should if
you know what I mean how many times have
I just said oh God why didn't I take a
breath why didn't I marinate it's gonna
say you got to marinate your juices
exactly let's soak it up
it's cool out for a minute yeah
um what do you think of someone who
again you were talking about Ann
Margaret in the studio system Raven
Simone was brought up very much in the
modern era version of that
um
what do you think of someone who says I
want autonomy I know who I am now I'm of
an age where I'm not interested in
people telling me who I should be or
what I should do this is my time you do
it's you have that weird like it's not a
dress rehearsal not even to do a Showbiz
term but just a lot of therapists out
there a lot of adults a lot of people
with experience would say like you get
one crack at this and you know so you
have to do it in a way that feels right
for you
I would also say to that same person
I don't know when it feels right for an
individual it's so different based on
life experiences
um it's interesting I I never asked
someone their age I think it won't
really tell me much about them because
people's life experience
throw those numbers into such
higgledy-piggledy
I've met young people who are incredibly
wise and Soulful and admirable and I've
met older people who I just think oh my
God you're so unevolved and I fear for
you so I I don't know well it's like
where are you at in the
self-actualization process which is very
much a process and you know it will
continue on until the end of your life
even for many I find this to be
interesting because Raven is someone
who's in her 30s so came up at a time
before social media when as she's
pointing out with this quote she was not
able to have any hand in telling her
story the story was told by others and
also Under the Disney Banner which is
like you know they're really they have a
they mold you to be a certain kind of
star that they want you to be and she
fell under that it's tragic the
statistics of how hard it is to make it
out alive and well from being a child
actor and that's been since day one and
that was all through television shows in
the 70s and so I
I
think
when I look at my kids and I just think
of the access and the bizarre nature of
doing too much too soon the only thing
that freaks me out more is the current
world yeah because kids have access to
too much and they just it's all there
it's interesting because you have these
Stars I mean Selena Gomez has talked
about this in the past I know Christina
Aguilera just did a Vogue life and looks
video in which she talked about the way
that when she first released her album
Her Image was crafted for her and then
she had her second album in which she
was kind of able to break out and be
herself so it's interesting seeing this
raven quote because it almost feels
familiar at this point this quote of I
had to be a certain way for so long I
was told how I needed to be and when I
entered into adulthood I found that this
voice within me that allowed me to be
who I am or I freed myself from whatever
circumstance I'd been put into I think
the strange thing is how normal reading
stories like Ravens has become and I
think one thing people like me people
that are not in the industry are
becoming more keen to is how much uh
these images are often not always
crafted by Studios by managers by agents
by Insidious forces that come in and say
you need to be this way or look this way
in order to succeed it's what keeps So
many actors in the closet is being told
yep if you are out if you are openly
lgbtq plus that is going to hinder your
career yeah so don't be who you are
because you'll work more you'll make
money more by suppressing who you are
and the implications that that's going
to have on a person's life outside of
just their career that's going to stay
with you and it takes a long time to
really figure yourself out and I think
you said it best too I think you'll
probably be doing it until the day we
move on to wherever we go right we are
all works in progress and never are we
we ever gonna totally have all the
answers I just hope that we will figure
a lot of things out along the way yeah
and it's interesting too in Raven's
perspective because it's like she had
this first part of her life in which she
was told to be a certain way and this is
all pre-social media then she becomes an
adult the self-actualization process
begins to take shape and then social
media comes into it right which on the
one hand good finally she has the
autonomy to tell her own story but on
the other hand the pressures that social
media bring about they rear their head
and so suddenly she's able to be herself
without being told who she needs to be
but the pressures from all around her
from other forces they come along also
to all parents out there these
cautionary like industry Tales all the
kids in the world are now exposed and at
risk due to social media there's so much
good that comes from social media there
are platforms and creative outlets and
Discovery and knowledge and you know
revolutions there's everything possible
on social media but as the polarity of
every side of two coins it has the other
yeah well said well I just never knew
I'd be contending with this as a parent
it's so ironic and Karma hilarious
okay everybody we have to take a quick
break and then we will be right back
and we're back okay our third story
Dolly Parton oh any Dolly's story is a
good story she drops a huge announcement
she told Paul Starr quote I do not think
I will ever tour again but I do know
I'll do special shows here and there now
and then maybe do a long weekend of
shows or even just a few shows at a
festival but I have no intention of
going on a full-blown tour ever again
Evan thoughts well ever heard of
something called shares farewell tour I
think Barbra Streisand had some too
there you go so I understand that she
might feel this way at this time and she
might feel this way wholeheartedly but
I have to believe and maybe maybe it's
more I want to believe that I have to
believe but I want to believe that we
will see more of Dolly on the stage that
said if she never does another tour
again I recognize how much she has given
our culture yeah and I will be grateful
for it
um but I'm hopeful that she this is
where she's at right now and as we were
saying earlier as we grow we evolve and
she might evolve and feel differently in
a few months or a few years she also
might be lived her life and wise and
know herself as well as we hoped
everyone would know themselves and you
know what's funny to me is how
much Vegas has come full circle like it
started out as This brilliant cachet Rat
Pack riddled you know and I'm sure
people would talk about Mafia and
gangsters and like the again the
polarity the other side of the coin but
Vegas went from being this like real
Class Act you know a level first-rate
um iconic Entertainer and then really
changed for a few decades and sort of
went all higgledy-piggledy and
hedonistic and fun and it's really back
to you can see Adele you can see Katy
Perry yeah you can see Gwen Stefani you
can this is Celine Dion
I could see and a Lady Gaga like you
name it these these people that have
these now called residency
I love that it's the not fatigue travel
aspect of a tour but the enjoyment of I
stay in the same place you guys come and
go you come to me and if Dolly Parton
ever did a Vegas residency
they would not be able to keep tickets
at the box office that thing would just
sell out every single show she would
ever do well the great thing about these
residencies too is there's no
expectation around how many shows they
give so Gaga for instance was able to go
and do a star is born or House of Gucci
while maintaining her residency without
people being like wait where'd you go
because it's like no no I'll be back
there are dates on the calendar here so
I think there's also an understanding
from the audience of when they're here
they'll be here you'll get the
notification and you can book your
ticket accordingly I will say
Counterpoint to I'm all for it Point
Counterpoint Counterpoint I do feel like
maybe like a few too many artists are
going to Vegas at this point where the
pendulum might have swung too far in the
other direction where I could use a
little bit more curation around who's
going to Vegas even if Adele that's
different does it get any bigger than
Adele oh no and I'm all about
so yes here for Adele but it just seems
like everyone's going to Vegas these
days and I'm a big fan of a traditional
stadium tour in the case of a dolly I
get it she's worked her whole life they
can come to her some of these artists
though as someone who was born and
raised in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and
appreciated when a really big artist
would come to my town okay there is
something that I feel like we need a
little bit of both I do appreciate the
going to a town I just went to like my
first concert in a very long time I went
to the Harry Styles concert and I went
in and um not to drop a name but Gail
King invited me and I was like Gail
anything you say anytime you say it so
sure I'll go
I was like almost
a little frustrated with people's
idolatry of the experience I was like I
get it I know it's more than a show I
almost went in with like a chip on my
shoulder I was like please don't sell me
on this anymore I get it yeah
it ends and I'm like oh my God I am so
converted oh wow I know we were going
that way the Church of Harry Styles I
already loved him going in but it was
more about how people just really did
not feel that his concert was a concert
but sort of a um
like a coming together of good energy
and a celebration of life it was more
than a concert and I just walked out
with my jaw on the floor thinking well
I'm a sucker and an idiot for not
believing everybody's Insanity I could
not have loved it more and I get excited
when I see people on social media going
to his show in in Austin Texas or a Los
Angeles because that show is traveling
and he's doing something very rare which
is staying in the places for these long
periods of time and maybe bringing out a
new art form to how people talk yes it's
something that's not talked about a ton
which is like the accessibility of these
artists I mean Taylor Swift just
announced her tour this week and I
looked at the dates I think they're 20
25 and my immediate like this dread set
in of knowing there's no way I'm going
to get a ticket because it's going to
sell out in an instant and with Harry
especially I think in Chicago he did
something like eight or ten shows it
allows people not only locals but people
to come come from the outskirts of
Chicago Etc to come and actually have a
chance of seeing these artists and as
someone whose life was radically
transformed through attending theater as
a kid and going to these concerts it's
deeply important that these artists do
Outreach Beyond just the big cities and
so as excited as I am about Taylor's
tour of course and I mentioned her
because she has a similar sort of like
that fandom that's very fervent there's
an inaccessibility to someone like her
which I get it like I'm not saying every
artist needs to do this but I like a
long lengthy multi-city take it to the
small towns tour I hear you I woke up
this morning
um to CNN who kicked off their new
Morning series this morning and it's
fascinating they have like a CBS
mornings GMA Today show with Don Lemon
and Caitlin Collins and it's a panel and
it was really exciting and I was like
and they were talking about it they're
like this is our first show right here
right now we're going to be coming to
you every morning and I was like yeah
why didn't CNN have this format that
makes sense and the first story I heard
was that Taylor Swift had set a brand
new record by having all 10 top all top
10 spots in the top 10 charts like her
it was wild and no woman has ever done
that in the history of music so well not
to digress too much but are you
listening to midnights
I am I really like uh purple hey no not
separate lavender lavender Haze that I I
love how it starts off it gets me right
in on that word go
um I'm really enjoying it uh and I'm
getting to know it the next story
Charlie puth says queer people dancing
to Madonna at a gay club inspired him to
make better music puth recently released
the single loser and told GQ he'd been
working on the track but was only half
happy with it when he drove past the
iconic gay club's pump and the Abbey
quote everybody was out dancing to
something that's not being played on the
radio and I think the lgbtq plus culture
is so ahead of its time culturally
sonically musically everythingly and I
was by myself and I saw everybody having
a great time and I literally heard a
different song in my head a new song was
born that's cool
out thoughts give it to me come on well
okay I will say I do think this is an
example of a quote that like has gotten
pulled out and dissected by a lot of
people that I think he probably meant
this as a very passive comment and when
sort of lifted it sort of can take on a
different meaning for a lot of people
when scrutinized have you ever had that
happen when you give an interview okay
I the this show have you ever had no
when was the last time I I think this
show has been very uh jarring for me
because even though I have uh stumbled
my entire existence
um in front of everyone I always felt
like it was me
um my responsibility my doings
um so I could never really be that upset
it's like well you did these things
you're accountable for yourself and I
don't really think about I don't believe
other people are investing any time in
me so I've just been able to like live
um
in a way that is very um
like accountable
um this show is weird because I'll talk
about something or someone else that'll
get picked up therefore it includes
something or someone else and then it's
not just my doing that makes me feel
uncomfortable like I'm so happy being a
stumbling or a mistake maker or a
learner or somebody who fails that
doesn't bother me if anyone else is
upset by anything I did or said about
someone else I'm devastated because I
don't ever want to hurt people or take
anyone down or offend or you know so
that has been interesting and it's due
to this show because that's when you're
like oh it's a talk show so you're gonna
talk all the time and then you might get
caught doing X Y and Z so that's a new
um a new take on it for me well I think
that and as a consumer of media myself
it's like taking things out of context
is often really fun right it's fun to
take a single quote that someone said
you know Kyle Richards says this on the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills reunion
you take that clip and you you put it
you know with this news story or
something and suddenly it's
recontextualized and it's funny to a lot
of people but it's interesting it's like
sampling and rap music totally but but
what you're kind of saying is well as
the person who maybe is saying the thing
that gets pulled it's not always fun
when you're in that position I I have
just been like I am fair game if anyone
else is involved I just so want to
keep the peace make people feel good
make people happy not have any weird
spin on anything whereas if it's just me
fair game okay everybody we have to take
a quick break and then we will be right
back
and we're back another casting update
Tony Danza will be playing Shay Diaz's
father on season two of and just like
that I mean Evan when it comes to who's
the boss is it Tony or Che thoughts this
is fun I'm just reading about this for
the very first time oh I'm also seeing
Jason momoa's butt which we'll get to in
a minute we'll get to he's fishing in
the nude
he's got the wow well okay I have to say
this I love mess and I love chaos and
one thing that I find really exciting
about and just like that season two
besides everything about it is the idea
that they're taking this character that
was pretty much universally loathed by
the audience and saying let's bring in
more of them and let's build out their
interior world let's let's show their
father let's let's keep doing this I
have to say I find that admirable from
The Writer's room I think it's exciting
the idea of you said you don't like this
thing not only are we going to do it
we're going to do more of it I'm like
I'm all for it I didn't get why the che
character was such a hot button issue
for people I was so thrown by Miranda
who's the like Sex in the City every
facet of one woman your sexual side your
business side your romantic poem poetic
side you know and you're sort of like
growing up trying to figure it all out
and be like you know living your best
wildest funnest ears it's it's different
facets of every woman
but Miranda represented something so
strongly for all those years that it was
so wild to be like wait hold on you're
but then I was like you know I wonder I
was really messy my whole life like a
hot mess I don't know if it looked like
that on the outside probably did here
and there I mean for sure it did here
and there but even in my 20s and 30s I
don't think people knew like how much I
was really struggling because I was
doing well professionally but in my
personal life like it was messy it was
fun and just amazing but it was messy
and now I feel much more buttoned up so
I guess you can have real role reversals
in your life so okay Miranda's now the
Messier one but I was like that's funny
that's a bigger
like wow factor to me than Che right I
mean yes we can have role reversals in
life do we need to see those play out on
the return of a beloved television
series which is beloved because of how
much people feel connected to these
characters and the three women who I
really thought had a spin-off within the
franchise were so strong and so good and
we're juggling spinning plates of these
characters are different that we know
and are beloved and we're meeting new
people we're meeting a lot of new people
and it's it and we're killing off people
that we knew oh my God I mean
congratulations on getting us all
talking yeah on episode one yeah I did
not see that coming no it it it's such a
wild ride but I think it's
representative of our Wild World we're
in and we're all here for it and it you
know wrapped itself up by the end and
we're all hungry for season two listen
uh last thing I'll say on this is just
with season two bring back the sex into
the Universe I feel like we were a
little sexless in season one event just
like that I just have questions okay
this story is so good
um Jason Momoa fishes in a loin cloth
and when that Ocean Breeze hits just
right he goes full moon this video is
everything have you seen it I've not
seen the video I've only seen the photo
which I'm staring at right now
I have seen the video I saved the video
but I do just want to say I'm very glad
that in order to have this conversation
properly we need the visual so I implore
those listening it's certainly
googleable
um it is a site it is a site it's
dare I say
I say what I thought it would be yeah
yeah spying in that sense it's so
it's so atomically perfect yes for him
and his body yeah and he's such an
extraordinary
being
um that everything about this is like
yeah now we're a little contextless from
these videos that he shared this just
popped up on the gram again loincloth
he's fishing there's a boat the other
gentlemen are wearing clothes like
they're fully clothed they're in like I
would say
newfangled uh you know Charter wear yeah
very much that so I I would love
additional context but then part of me
is like do I need the contacts because
all the context is in those cheeks
um by the way I just want to do this
here
whatever
okay so that was uh manunalu I am
drinking Jason momoa's water
um I when we started the show Jason
momoa's company Manu nalu kindly said
that they could be the official water of
our show so since this show has launched
and we're in our third season we have
nothing but and have since day one
nothing but Manu nalu and it's my
favorite water in the world I'm never
without this water it's my very favorite
I find him just so appealing when he was
on that Hawaiian Airlines flight passing
out the waters everything he does he
shaved his head and on wait hold on a
second he has a top bun in this picture
he does so this is pre the head shave
we're gonna need we're going to need a
recreation post head shave
um he is I just love that he is bringing
all these messages with his very large
career yeah and large booty I mean I'm
looking at the guy in the charter
garment and I feel bad for him that he's
not in a loincloth like yeah he doesn't
look cool Jason Momoa looks cool
Counterpoint he gets to be on the boat
with Jason Momoa I don't know if he's I
I don't know
I feel like you should have been on that
boat and not him listen I'll drink the
water oh I I will drink the water I I
it's true and then I can't thank you
enough for your time and your expertise
and your knowledge and your you know
background that you bring to all the
things that you do
um because you're a big spoken you know
out there figure but you've got the
goods to back it up you've done your
research you've been around you've done
the homework it's really fun I've been
on your feet for as long as I can
remember and I was like oh my God we're
gonna get to do the podcast with him no
way this is so cool so thank you truly
well thank you I just have to reflect
back to you as a fellow interviewer
myself you Excel so much at this art
form because I think a lot of people
approach it from the I'm going to ask a
question and get an answer and the
reason Drew why your Clips continue to
go viral on the Internet is because of
the enthusiasm that you bring to your
interviews that both the audience and
the person you're in conversation with
feel you have an energy that you emanate
that is not present in the television
space at at this time and I think you
your pure love of celebrity and pop
culture and culture and Ina Garten and
all these things like your that
enthusiasm we all feel it and so I think
that you you obviously have excelled in
acting your whole life but this career
venture has been a true like knockout
but like die happy that this has been
Drew's news and uh I don't know if maybe
you're looking for a revelation to set
you on the second half of your life on a
better path than the first half was
spent then maybe tell somebody about
this podcast or if you just want to
escape into you know
stories that take you away from yourself
because you're so sick of yourself then
you can listen to this podcast and if
you just want to hear about weird things
happening in the world we'll look no
further or hear no further we're here
for you totally and if you are desperate
for someone to see you and take another
road into who you are well then
we're here for that too we see you and
thank you so much for spending your time
with us because all of this at the end
of the day is really for you and so
please take it with you
[Music]